meagan Markel is showing off her baby
bump on a royal night out with Prince
Harry let's dive into it okay so the
Duchess of Sussex and Prince Harry were
draped in matching black and white and
Megan's debut at the Royal Variety
Performance today Cassie what do we
think about Megan's dress oh you know
I'm big for embellishments and sequins
and I love the top of this so from my
research it is a Sofia couture gown I'm
not gonna lie I not crazy about the
halter strap okay I think it's a little
dated but I think she can you know
obviously she is carrying a baby you
have to keep the dress up you don't want
too much cleavage showing you are a
royal I mean she's not gonna break yeah
she's not gonna break royal protocol
here she needs those straps to stay
conservative but that bump oh my
goodness this is one of the first times
you've really got a good view of it so
right because this is kind of like their
first you know one of her first outing
since their tour down under new zealand
in australia and here you see the video
of them chatting with some of the
performers from the Hamilton musical so
yeah a little light a little date night
action you're right you know other than
the highlighter that's popping on her
cheekbones she has a glow blowing she
has that pregnancy glow I love it so
what they're at right now the Royal
Variety Performance in London it's an
annual fundraiser in the entertainment
industry in London that raises money for
the Royal Variety charities so good
little dinner always doing that yeah oh
is it for a good cause we love making it
Harry a key breaking that royal protocol
and Megan looks fabulous
we love the Royals okay
[Music]
[Applause]